[Music]
how's go everybody's lord-master here
from lords of gaming that net I'm here
of lad from another indie studio here to
talk about jackass so we were talking
about Jack act started screen just a
house like what's the payment plane
alright so Jack acts is a indie game
from developers from Philippines so the
developer he made this game with four
characters who are all leaves and
they're all female so it's based on his
three daughters and wife so it's a very
hardcore 2d platformer and we have a
special axe throwing mechanic which you
throw the axe you teleport to the axe
and it gives you a momentum and use that
to go through the levels so it's very
technical very difficult and it's up to
four players online and offline and it's
coming out later this year force which
PlayStation Xbox and PC as well
oh sorry so it's all based on the
Filipino mythology yeah that's pretty
much it
great great great short pitch yeah it's
great
so you talked a little bit about the
game itself so tell us a bit about the
level and that he's going through right
now alright so this is the second level
this is the desert level so it's a bit
more hardcore actually it's a little bit
too difficult so we're gonna be swapping
to the first level which is the snow
level with the Yeti balls because well
not oh not many people can get through
this level right now we just noticed it
the first day and yeah so we're gonna be
swapping it so it tells a little bit
about how players should tackle this
kind of level if they're stopped so
first you need to get used to the
momentum and their speed because there's
also a little bit of a sliding factor
when you're doing the platforms and you
really need to master the throwing axe
in multi directions and teleporting to
the axe and you need to time the
momentum right so you get so you land
your platforms so that gets used to it
and also with the buttons because you
get the - button the flowing the ax
button teleporting to the axe
times after teleporting you have to
throw the axe again so it requires a
little bit of finger coordination so it
takes some time to get used to it but
once you get used to it it becomes a bit
easier but in the beginning you will
struggle to look at the controller and
then at the screen the controller and
the screen so we said that it's not a
muscle memory that comes with it too so
so what's that mean for later levels
what kind of challenge going to get to
players that it gets even crazier where
there's no platforms and you have to
gain momentum for like shooting cannons
and you just keep going long levels
where it's just air and little hooks but
you can't stay in the hooks they they
act like as a swing so you have to keep
like throwing the axe teleporting using
the momentum catching the axe back
throwing the axe and like like
multi-step to transfer big gaps sounds
sounds like the ultimate brain teaser
and and play your challenge for players
out there now I had to ask what's what's
the behind named Jack axe honestly man I
actually have no idea it's all it's all
good so it's a great name for the game
here so tell us when it comes to
platforms and what platform is well
right so it's coming in 2020 so this
year and it's going to be on switch
PlayStation Xbox and PC perfect thank
you so much thanks much flat that was
Jack axes Lord motto from Lords of game
net
[Music]